estas manifestaciones han comenzado
temprano en distintos puntos de Israel y
tienen como objetivo generar una
disrupción como llaman los manifestantes
interrumpir la vida cotidiana comenzaron
con bloqueos y marchas de padres y
estudiantes también un bloqueo de
reservistas en el puerto de haifa en el
norte de Israel y lo principal pasa
ahora por una un intento de interrupción
en una de las autopistas principales
desde la viven donde la policía ya está
comenzando a intervenir incluso con
violencia para desplazar a los
manifestantes y el foco principal es
alrededor del aeropuerto bengurión desde
donde se espera que el Primer Ministro
Benjamín taniak parta para su visita de
13 días a Roma previamente se reúne con
el ministro de defensa estadounidense
Eloy dustin quien vino a Israel de
visita y tuvo que alterar alterar
también sus planes por estas protestas
de ahí que las reuniones Se estén
llevando a cabo en el mismo aeropuerto
para el resto de la jornada hay todavía
más convocatorias una de las principales
es una protesta frente a la casa del
ministro de Justicia
es el ideólogo de esta reforma judicial
y también una marcha de antorchas por la
noche en terapia Federico Cuál es el
estado del tratamiento de las reformas
recordemos que esta reforma judicial se
compone de varios proyectos de ley los
principales son los que apuntan a
alterar la el comité que elige a los
jueces dándole una mayoría al gobierno
de turno Y también restringir las
capacidades de la Corte Suprema para
revisar las leyes estos estos primeros
proyectos de ley han pasado la primera
de las tres lecturas necesarias en la
keneset esta semana hubo un pequeño
parón en el trámite parlamentario debido
a la festividad judía de piuring pero se
espera que el fin de semana continúen
Los debates en la kenneced para avanzar
con estos proyectos de ley el gobierno
tiene como objetivo que sean aprobados
antes de la festividad del pesaje la
Pascua judía que es a inicios de abril
el diálogo entre el gobierno y la
oposición está bloqueado no ni siquiera
tiene un Punto de partida porque la
oposición exige que el gobierno frene el
trámite parlamentario Mientras que el
gobierno no está dispuesto a esto y han
surgido algunas alternativas que se
presentan como más moderadas pero que
tampoco conforman a la oposición
Mientras tanto el impacto ya se empieza
a sentir por ejemplo en el sector
económico sobre todo en el de la alta
tecnología con algunas empresas que han
anunciado el retiro de parte de sus
fondos de Israel y la posibilidad de
mudar sus operaciones fuera de este
territorio